build it draw it play it vsauce this is
your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people
this is bdp building sean avery creates
cd sculptures using wire mesh frames
broken cd fragments and hot glue he
creates small medium and large animal
sculptures for commission simply tell
him the size the type of animal and what
color cds to use and he can build it
using an antique metronome this kinetic
sculpture takes flight to know yoon has
an entire series of incredible metal
works dedicated to the motion of wings
including suspended wings confined wings
and segmented wings
phil cotton's built faster a custom hand
cranked machine that creates awesome
faceted objects facets are flat faces on
geometric shapes the faster has been
used to create resin lampshades vases
and even a side table all with an eerie
digital quality finally lichtenberg
figures are captured lightning
sculptures these incredible works of art
are created by electrically charging a
surface of insulating materials like
acrylic and then dielectric breakdown
removes the excess charge that was
trapped creating the discharge which
creates the magnificent pattern
try an artist in germany created these
sound paintings by splattering paint on
a scrim over the diaphragm of a speaker
martin klimas cranked music ranging from
miles davis to craftwork and captured
the colorful results with a shutter
speed of 1 7 000 of a second malaysian
artist hong yi harnesses the staining
power of coffee for her unique portraits
this time lapse shows the delicate
12-hour process from using the saucer as
a coffee palette to dip the bottom of
the cup into and transfer her medium of
choice now the incredible illustrations
of jason edmundson
finally roberto salvador created this
series of screaming heroes including
conida snake pliskin and some bearded
texas ranger guy play it sound machines
is a visual instrument that translates
concentric patterns into control signals
that are then processed by software
three musicians from around the world
got together for this cover of gojira's
heaviest matter of the universe with
vocals from a dinosaur
busking is performing in public places
colin huggins is a piano busker who
hauls a 650 pound baby grand piano
through new york city
finally u900 is a japanese ukulele duo
of amigurumi animals which is the
japanese art of crocheted animals or
toys
submit your own bdp's as a personal
message here on youtube or share them
with everyone over at facebook.com
vsauce gaming and as always thanks for
watching
the closing of a trilogy
the film was
you